what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here now I'm John we are going to be
doing a patron video request one of our
reward tiers on patreon whatever video
you request we must definitely do and
put up on YouTube and today comes from
new patronage act Norval
[ __ ] Floyd that's like a family first
name that's been passed down to him it's
guys a really cool dude originally from
l.a now lives in Vegas guy is a writer
editor director he does it all and it
has a production company he's a CEO
founder NJC productions he put together
a horror movie that has a trailer out
for an independent film to have almost
10,000 views on your trailer it's pretty
good that's pretty damn good called
beyond deceived and what he says it's
inspired by a Rick and Morty episode
called total Rick call you know John
seen that episode I have not cuz I wanna
see three episodes of Rick and Morty
you're behind gee oh yeah what's gonna
get this at all you're not gonna miss a
pible were standing here we go
radar from blood and gore violence and
language I love all those things as do
God whoa music before the clip even
starts
I want to thank you all for the
invitation
[Music]
those blues whoa
like that
Lake are you Norval
I told you
trying to leave it out it's always been
ten of us ever since the party started
look at the paper Lucas seven knock time
whoa whoa too many spoilers in your own
trailer over
[Music]
stunt work
we go
it's gone out with the sink
[Music]
whoa
using your makeup on this burger
[Music]
[Music]
it's not about title yeah that's a
really good title yeah so is this a
whole movie or is this like concept
trailer he said he was finished putting
together a movie kind of feels like a
concept trailer no but there's some good
makeup in there for sure yeah yeah yeah
well I like your colors and stuff and I
think it's cool taking the idea of that
episode and turning it into a horror
mean there is an actual orbit gonna be a
comedy yeah like taking it super
seriously and making it sort of paranoid
almost like the thing or something like
that
taking that mood cuz you know the Rick
and Morty episode is gonna be zany
anyway yeah you know mr. poopy butthole
it's like the invitation meats super
low-budget supernatural sci-fi strange
doppelganger thing yeah are these all
your friends I imagine these are all
your buddies and you were like let me
write for my friends that's the vibe I
get looks like you had a really fun time
slapping this all together man oh yeah
well the more of these you do you know
the better they've all get yes in terms
of cutting a trailer it's good practice
for that and then making an actual you
know feature I mean if you're working on
an actual feature of a that's the
invaluable experience again 5 to 10
minutes sketches that we do every few
months on this channel ain't an easy
task so kudos to you for being able to
get all your buddies together and just
to manage it was to manage everybody and
get I guess it's hard stuff we can sit
here and talk about some obvious
technical criticisms in terms of like
audio in certain shots yeah I mean yeah
it's it's hard it's a challenge but
often times and stuff like this when
you're putting together kind of an epic
scale trailer there could be a rather
kind charm to watching a low-budget film
like this there's so many times I've
seen trailers for movies where I'm like
well this looks kind of amateur the
audio and the lighting doesn't really
work here then you watch the movie and
and all the times you're like oh those
really enjoy a surprisingly you know
that's kind of the vibe up pick it up
here you know there's a lot of amateur
qualities here at the same time I'm like
I'm sure that there's probably something
pretty enjoyable within here though and
are actually watching the total film oh
yeah well I mean I like I said I like
the idea that you're taking here you
know and
warping into a horror movie and it seems
like at least for the tone and stuff
like that you got a good grip on you
know the tension yes there's a sort of
rising tension throughout this and like
yeah you could nitpick stuff but you
know I can see the earmarks of like
you're thinking about color thinking
about composition like it's hard to
shoot in your home you know like
especially with a lot of people think
this was in his home that would be my
guess
no somebody's please no no no no no yeah
yeah you're getting your mates together
and coming up with a concept that you
can shoot sort of on your own
yeah even throwing in just a few makeup
effects and stuff and and that cool
title with the dutching angle or the
house and whatnot I can see the sense of
your style and I'm curious to see more
of what you produce yeah and let us know
if this is a trailer concept we actually
shot a whole thing because it was a
pretty long trailer so I'm like
wondering it did you shoot for the
trailer oh yeah yeah because I imagine
there's some fun stuff and some cool
stuff to be had within this thing best
of luck to how it turns out I can't wait
to have a google hangout with you and
talk more about what inspired this
project and everything buddy cuz I've
had a birthday party go exactly like
this oh yeah I'm gonna kill people who
aren't real yeah worse cuz like you love
them I've invited 30 people to a party
and then next thing I know there's like
31 and then there's 32 oh wow no don't
even remind me well truth but I just
forgot I have added them oh that was
that the plot of this movie twisted the
end well the way the episode works is
there's an alien creature who worms its
way into your life by creating a person
that you believe has just always been
there and you know there are earmarks as
to how you know it's sort of mystery of
the episode we get by the end of the
episode they're a bunch of people and
they're like you can't kill Uncle squig
we love uncle squig and uncle squig is
like totally ridiculous but they're all
like no we've known him forever right
and then yeah it becomes this thing of
like who's real well that's fascinating
it's a pretty good concept you know I
don't like about this what where's the
Asian friends all I see are white people
and black people I love diversity
polarizing but where are the Asians
that's it you leave all the Hispanics
you leave out the Arabs inches of
where's the Asian people from indigenous
lands I have confusing racism I want to
see certain races but only specifically
well thanks Norval looking forward to
talking later this week you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects take care
people